Macchiarini was a superstar surgeon.
He’s this good-looking man of mystery.
A miracle worker.
His technique was groundbreaking.
The artificial trachea
for people who have problems
with their windpipe.
But the problem is...
Paolo’s surgeries are failing.
Paolo was selling a miracle.
People want to believe in a miracle.
But something is off.
He was just so desperate to
show this idea could work.
And that had deadly consequences.
Patient is developing all sorts of complications.
Paolo’s synthetic trachea clogs up.
The feeling that you’re about to suffocate
all the time.
It was medical torture.
He lied consistently throughout his career
about his credentials.
Paolo was fooling everybody
professionally and personally.
Macchiarini lied about
the success of the patients.
While Paolo’s patients were dying,
there were patients being actively recruited
and operated on.
He had to be stopped.
For me the question has always been...
How did he get away with it
for as long as he did?